[موسيقى]
شكرا على الترحيب الجميل
انا احمد كباره ومعظم حياتي انا كان عندي
مين هنا يعرف يعني
ده الاحساس
اللي انت اللي انت ده مش مكانك
اللي انا مش عارف اعمل اللي انا بحاول
اعمله
فانا رحلتي في المزيكا او الفن ابتدت من
اكتر من 15 سنه وفي الوقت ده ما كانش عندي
اي بليف اللي انا فنان او بقدر اقدم اي
حاجه بس في خلال 15 سنه حاجات كتيره
اتغيرت نرجع للتيم بتاع النهارده
ازاي
ايه اللي بيحصل لما بيكون عندك حلم او
انبشن لما بتتخيل نفسك ازاي بتوصل او
بتتغير او بتتحول
لذهنك او بتحقق طموحك
انا لسه دلوقتي كل ما بيجي لي شغل او يكون
في حاجه بفكر ايه ده انا مش هعرف مش هعرف
اعملها انا مش فنان انا معرفش اي حاجه بس
لما يجي وقت واقدم الشغل
بكون واثق من الشغل ده فايه اللي اتغير
جوايا
فانا
لما بيجي لك احساس انزايتي او احساس
اللي انت خايف من حاجه
ده معناها ان انت ما جهزتها ما جهزتش نفسك
لها
يعني
او ما فيش
ايه اللي بيحصل في خلال الفتره لما بيكون
عندي يجيلي الشغل وبعد كده بقدمه اللي كل
يوم بعمل حاجه صغيره في الشغل ده لغايه
مثلا لو عندي حفله وفي فرقه بحاول اعمل
كتيره وده الفرق التجهيزه ده بيجي مش بتحس
به بسراكم وده هو تراكم الخبره فنرجع
لرحلتي اول ما ابتديت انا زي معظم الشباب
حاولت كنت عايز ابقى مهندس دكتور مهندس
كلنا كلنا لازم نبقى دكاتره مهندسين لكن
انا بحب المزيكا
ومنجحتش لما حاولت ادخل ادرس هندسه او
حاجه
بس لما ابتديت ادرس هندسه صوت ومزيكا في
الاول ما كنتش عارف اي حاجه
وكل يوم انا بدوده او بسكتش
ومع مر الوقت
بقى ودني بقت عندها اكتر بعرف اسمع او
اتخيل خيالي وسع لما بشتغل في مختلفه لما
يجي فنانه ويقول لي انا عايز اعمل اللون
كذا او كذا
فنرجع للاحساس
امتى انا حسيت اه لا هو ده انا فنان ونرجع
للهويه
انا السنه اللي فاتت صديقي بعث لي دي ام
على انستجرام وده ولد ممكن تعرفهم من
المدرسه مصطفى
وبعدين عزمني البيت ولانه هو كان بيحب
فنانه بشتغل معاه جدا وشافني في حفله وقال
لي انت احمد كبار من رئاسه الالسن مدرسه
قلت له ايوه انا احمد في مباراه
الاسهم ازيك يا مصطفى وعزمني بيته فقال لي
ايه احساسك اللي انت دلوقتي
ميزه او فنان اللي انت حققت حلمك
وقفت وفكرت كده عمري ما حسيت نرجع اللي
انا بقيت
اللي كان في مخي
بس قلت له ايوه انا دلوقتي عشان الشغل
بتاعي انا بقيت اه يعني الناس بينزلوا لي
اللي انا كذا
فنرجع للحته
مش مهم انا ما عنديش اي بليف في حاجه
اسمها في حاجه اسمها اللي انت كل يوم تبذل
مجهود وانتم عارفين طبعا حته
عشان تكتسب اي خبره وتراكم الوقت
والمجهود ده هتشوفوا التغيير اللي هيحصل
فيك ده هيحصل واحده واحده
وانا مش في البلاي ما عنديش اي اعتقاد
السلف
الكلمه دي ناس بتحب تقولها كتير هو ده
برضو بيتبني باللي كل يوم بتعمل حاجه حتى
لو انت مش عارف دي هتوظفها ازاي
وايه هدف من اللي انا بعمله وهو ده الفن
انا في اعتقادي انت مش عارف بالضبط انت
هتعمل ايه
كلنا بنخاف من المجهول
اللي انا حياتي هتمشي ازاي ما نعرفش بكره
هيبقى ايه لكن بالتجهيز بالتمرين
بالقراءه كل ده بيوصلك بيغير فيك التحول
فانا لما نرجع للستيم بتاع النهارده
اللي انت كله خطوه بتتهور وفجاه بتلاقي
نفسك تحولت لحاجه يمكن انت ما كنتش
متوقعها لان انا عمري ما كنت فاكر ان انا
ابقى
والنهارده هلعب لكم بالجهاز الغريب ده
اللي انا بقى لي سبع سنين بجمع حته حته
ومش عارف هو بيعمل ايه لان معظمنا طبعا
دلوقتي بنعمل مزيكا بالكمبيوتر بس انا بحب
اوصل اسلاك واجرب والنهارده هجرب لكم حاجه
شكرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]